somebody just put a super chat and they
said what happened on nick fuentes
yeah no uh nick fuentes uh was a user
who um we removed from the platform and
he was inviting people to uh be a part
of his um
be a part of a group that i think is
pretty clearly uh uh racist and doesn't
fit with um within our terms of service
and look uh i'm work you're never gonna
get everything perfect you're gonna have
people who are critics from different
sides but i'm not going to allow
getter to become the okay cupid of the
white nationalist set i'm just not what
what did nico fuentes say what group was
it uh so the gripers
okay i got it so nick if you want to
pull up his wikipedia nick joseph
fuentes is in
american far right and white nationals
political commentator live streaming the
anti-defamation league has described
fuentes as a white supremacist a former
youtuber his channel was permanently
suspended in february 2024 violating
youtube hate speech
got it so it's not like you kicked off
fuentes has feuded with turning point
usa and it's founder charlie kirk for
supporting
views that fuentes believes to be
insufficiently conservative in october
tonight followers when
gripers began heckling turning point
cultural war tour including a speaking
event for donald trump jr okay got it so
it's not like you kicked off a liberal
you kicked off somebody that would be a
far right person they kicked off a
ghetto look and it's i don't even think
it's a an idiot ideological thing i mean
i think when you're but it is though
because twitter you know most people
would say a lot of people that twitter
kicks off are people that are on the
right not necessarily a lot of people on
the left that's why but i think there's
i think there's a difference between
someone who is actively preaching or
recruiting for white nationalism versus
say a political ideology in my opinion
it might be
arguing over semantics on this one so
maybe i'm
looking at it too narrowly um but again
a getter is a platform where we do have
uh terms of service that are pretty
clearly stated uh we don't put up we
don't have any tolerance for racial
religious epithets uh we don't have
pornography there's plenty of places to
get porn we twitter's got a lot of
points on twitter twitter's got a lot of
pornography yesterday but twitter allows
you to go oh porn okay
and you know what porn is porn is like
pornhub like yeah we can check it out
with that being said how do you balance
hate speech and freedom of speech
where's the line that's a good question
because it's leading me to the next
question okay so a really good question
and again we think what we've found with
getter is the sweet spot of the bat
where we allow people to express
themselves politically where they know
that they'll never be censored
algorithmed d-platformed shadow banned
any of that nonsense for expressing
their political beliefs whether you're
on the left or the right where
some people join the platform aren't
even that into politics maybe they just
don't like big tech or they're
inherently distrustful of it and they
want to they want to try a new platform
so our typically in most western
countries your free speech rights extend
right up to the point where you start to
infringe on someone else's rights
obviously things such as doxing which we
had to go and suspend a very popular
account for doxing just the other day
they put up some someone's address and
we had to go and take that down that's
not something we put up what is this
term doxing doxing is when you go and
put out say publicly identifiable or
publicly sensitive information so you
can't post somebody say home address and
say hey we dislike this person here's
their home address like that's that's
that's what you'd call doxxing or here's
someone's credit card number or here's
someone's social security number that's
the kind of thing that's doxing or the
other thing too if someone's outright
pushing for illegal behavior or
threatening self-harm
you know for example if someone said hey
go out there and if you cut your left
arm off you can care covet okay that
would be the type of thing where that
would be something that would
potentially lead to lead to self-harm
the but your point out that you bring up
is there's always going to be that rub
between a free speech paris who says any
restriction wait a minute are you being
hypocritical or people are saying we
want to make sure that we keep the
platform safe and again we're never
going to get it right 100 of the time
but our only ideological driver is the
fact that we want to make sure that
people
we support free speech and that we
oppose cancer culture so that there's no
political discrimination that goes into
it like the big tech platforms where
they pick winners and losers based on
whether they agree with you well what
what did nick say that got him kicked
off what was specifically what was what
was the message he sent
uh he posted a message that was
effectively recruiting people or trying
to identify with uh trying to organize
uh who are additional grapers that were
on the platform what's wrong with that
because then you're inviting uh then
that's trying to organize people who are
white nationalist group uh that we think
is uh doesn't fit with our terms of
service
okay so so
so then
it's okay so you got to realize i don't
agree with what he agrees with though
the part i'm thinking about is if your
position is free thinkers
you're pushing that off then somebody
may say well there is criterias to it so
yeah and the only thing pat just did
just be clear here
there are
uh there are plenty of places where he
can go in and preach white nationalism
and if you want to go and preach white
nationalism then you can go to a
different platform it's your choice as a
consumer we believe that our community
does not want to see that we believe
that if we're going to scale if we're
going to be a true competitor to big
tech these are the parameters that we're
going to keep people safe within this
and hey some people are going to agree
with it some people aren't but what
we're providing is so much
different and so much better than any of
the big technologies fully free thinker
though then it's not fully free thinker
because you're not allowing me to think
for myself that i disagree with the guy
it is free thinking to a limit because
let me explain what i mean by in every
platform every platform is and that's
leading me to so for example i like
interviewing communists genuinely one of
my favorite interviews when i have a guy
i'm sitting with that's a communist i
enjoy that interview i know it sounds
weird and i've not done one not two not
three
any major name that's a communist i want
to sit and cure the only reason they're
not i haven't interviewed them is
because they've said no not because i
haven't invited them i enjoy talking to
them because i want to know what makes
you think the way you do and i let the
audience say
screw pat i don't agree with them that
was unfair or you know what i don't
agree with the other guy i agree with
pat great but they get to make a
decision for themselves
the part i think about what what gives
us a lot of confidence in america what
what gives you and i a lot of confidence
to live in america it's a piece of paper
right what is that piece p piece of
paper called
the constitution right
and why is it so powerful because i
can't just erase it and say ah you know
what yeah
i don't know you know i don't know about
this part the constitution is here's
what the founding fathers founded this
country on right i think
for a you're a small virtual government
right now
well you got five million people living
there your small state essentially if
you think about it you are what's a
state with 5 million people idaho i
don't know the number but 5 million is a
you're a state right essentially or
you're a small country okay
that's out there but 5 million is 5
million and you are a virtual government
essentially you are a virtual nation
essentially so is twitter so is facebook
so it's youtube that's what you're
building
i think the right way to do it it's just
my feedback you have to you can take it
you cannot take it i just give them the
feedback
is to put a constitution out there
saying these are the things that will
never be changed
and here's what we're putting on paper
so i go to the website and say this is
getter's constitution
this is what we'll tolerate this is what
we won't tolerate so i had a meeting at
uh jekyll island
and i pulled my guys aside and i took
them out there and i'm showing them
rockefeller's house and i'm showing them
all these guys out so it's a very good
experience if you've been to jekyll
island and in the room where the federal
you know the whole federal reserve got
started with the whole meetings and all
that stuff in 1906 or
when when it became official we're in
the room we're having all these
conversations they're sensitive historic
and i said i want us to write out our
constitution of i we never okay so
i
will da da da we had 13 i's we had 13
weeds we have 13 nevers
so the i is i will set the best example
as a leader i that are his eyes right
the we was we collectively
will do x y z there never was never will
we compromise dot dot dot never will we
accept dot dot dot never will we do the
reason why i share that with our field
force is because if somebody sees that
and they say yeah i don't like it they
leave
but if somebody sees that and they say
oh my god this is home i'm here to stay
and not only am i here to stay
i'm going to tell the world about the
eye we never write i'm gonna go tell the
world about this whole thing
i think the right virtual government to
do it the right way
is to create a constitution that they
themselves will be held accountable
if they cross the line with that
constitution i may be wrong but i think
it's very important for the user to have
trust with you
i i completely agree and i think that to
that point uh so we we have our terms of
service which largely
i mean it's a contract it's the one
thing that people sign or that they
check off when they join anything
whether it's um you know twitter
facebook nobody reads terms it's about
to say that but so zero so
to that point that's obviously very
legalistic and very and the reason why
it reads legalistic is because it's your
contract
so we're actually we just hired a brand
new uh director of moderation who's
going through and actually putting
together the formal community guidelines
that'll have very specifics of
rules of the road essentially
i think that'll probably take it's
written now but we're just going through
some some refinement a couple of few
weeks we'll have that posted so to your
point that will then be our constitution
that we post with more granular more
kind of real world details of kind of
the the do's and don'ts of the platform
so people fully understand it and like i
said look we're not going to get
everything right every time now we're
going to continue to grow there are
different dynamics different situations
that come up and i spent i knew i was
going to spend a lot of time on
moderation when i took on this challenge
especially after the d platforming of
january 6 and everything i didn't maybe
i was going to spend quite this much
time on moderation and keep in mind
right now we're largely talking about
the u.s
i'm dealing with on the global level so
then i'm dealing with ofcom with regard
to the uk i'm dealing with the german
law enforcement i'm dealing with people
in all around the world and look getter
is and one of the kind of unique things
about it we're only 50 u.s and prior to
the rogan explosion
rogan and tucker coming on board we're
only 37 percent u.s i made it i made the
commitment when we launched this thing
this could be a global platform not just
because of where i wanted to go for
scale but also to make sure it wasn't an
american echo chamber and so brazil is
about 15 percent brazil second
brazil second who's third uh so uk is
third and just below 10. germany is
right behind them and france is right
behind them and then japan is uh then
japan and canada are like number six and
seven uh and so we've so the countries
where we have teams where we're out
working obviously the us brazil uk
france germany and then i just expanded
this quarter uh for japan india and
colombia and so those are kind of our
our big targets i think india is good
for you uh i think india is good for you
because there's a lot of free thinkers
in india and their enemy is also the
same enemy which is the china they're
not a fan of china they banned a hundred
apps in china so and so to that point
it's almost like we synced up beforehand
the drivers will be found in a lot of
our international markets where we're
targeting obviously you can get us
globally unless the government's
blocking it actually literally the day
we kicked off i think we had ten or
twenty thousand people sign up for
venezuela and then after that first day
going silence yeah they just as like you
know said no one else is getting it but
what we found is proximity to communism
and socialism is a huge driver so for
example people in colombia and brazil
where you're seeing all the people
fleeing from venezuela are massive
drivers south florida where you have
such a big cuban american community
massive getter user base people who are
concerned about india as you said um
also elections that are coming up in
countries where there are elections in
2022 you see a lot more political
activity people are kind of supercharged
and paying attention to it and then of
course the big one is where you have
both big tech and governments who are
coming in trying to silence people and
there's a huge difference i mean you
take a look at colombia which literally
has a no censorship clause in their own
concert constitution or it's essentially
an amendment that they had colombia
colombia brazil doesn't have their
version of a us first uh first amendment
they do not have any aspect of free
speech which kind of blew my mind this
is a major democracy uh you know uh
certainly in south america a big power
with a supermarket to the world when it
comes to beef markets and other things
you have the
single biggest japanese community
outside of japan and they don't have
that in fact i met the deputy carol de
tony who's writing their version of the
first amendment and i was like wait a
minute you guys don't have that she goes
nowhere in our constitution doesn't
protect it we take for granted
our first amendment rights ability to
express ourselves and obviously look at
your background where you grew up no
questions
i mean people get get killed for you
know being on the wrong side of the
street uh it's you know pretty nutty so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]